- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our Daily Homeroom.
For those of y'all who are new to this,
this is something that we
started doing a few weeks ago
as we started seeing
the mass school closures
and obviously Khan Academy,
we're a not-for-profit
with a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And we realized that as
the schools were closing,
we wanted to put our resources together
so they could be as useful as possible
for you, the student,
the teacher, the parent.
And we also wanted to
provide more supports
especially since all of us
are now socially distanced,
so that we can feel connected,
so that we could answer
each other's questions,
so that we can support each other.
And so we've been
running teacher webinars,
parent webinars and we have
been doing this Daily Homeroom
which is just a way to connect,
talk about whatever
y'all have on your mind
and to have interesting guests.
Now before we get into the meat
of the homeroom so to speak,
I will say what I always
say, a reminder that we are
a not-for-profit.
We are funded with
philanthropic donations.
We were running at a deficit,
even before this COVID crisis hit
and now our traffic is about 2.5X, 3X
of what it typically is
and so our costs have gone more
and we wanna provide more supports.
So if you are in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
I do wanna give special thanks
to several corporate partners
who have stepped up in the last few weeks,
really in record time,
to help Khan Academy
with this effort.
Bank of America,
Novartis, Google.org, AT&T
and of course there's many
other long-time supporters
but we still need more help.
We're still digging into our reserves
in order to stay operational.
So now that I've given you my plug,
I wanna introduce our guest.
You know, we've had a lot of questions
about all things academic.
How do we keep learning in math?
How do we keep learning in the humanities
and how do you keep learning
in foreign language?
And so I have today, Luis von Ahn,
a old friend of mine who is
the founder, CEO of Duolingo.
Many of y'all might be familiar.
It's a place, it's an app,
where you can learn languages for free.
But I don't know, Luis, you're
more qualified than I am.
Tell me about what y'all do at Duolingo.
- Well thank you for having me, Sal.
And thank you for this initiative.
It's great that you guys are doing it.
Well at Duolingo, I
mean, we teach languages,
that's the main thing we do.
You can either do it online
in a computer at Duolingo.com
or you can download an
iPhone app or an Android app.
It's free to learn, it's
entirely free to learn
and you can learn as much
as you want for free.
And the other thing is
that we spend a lot of time
making sure that it's fun to
learn a language with Duolingo.
So it feels a lot like
you're playing a game
when you're learning on Duolingo.
We've worked really hard on that.
- And I can see,
we're seeing some screenshots
now from Duolingo.
And Luis, I guess, how were
people using Duolingo before?
Was it being integrated with
your kind of traditional
you know, high school classes in languages
or is it mainly adults who
are trying to learn maybe
for a business trip?
And how are you seeing the usage change
since the crisis began?
- Yeah, I mean, we have a ton of users.
I mean, we have over 300
million users worldwide.
It's all over the place.
The age range is from you know,
six, seven, eight years old
to 90 some years old.
There's, as far as we know,
we don't know for a fact
because we don't really track this,
anybody can really use
Duolingo, but as far as we know
about 25% of our language
classrooms in the U.S.
Use Duolingo in one way or another.
So we do have a lot of student
users but we also have a lot
of adult users who are just you know,
wanting to improve on their
high school French or something.
Since everybody's been staying
at home, we've seen our usage
go up quite a bit.
And you know, our user
base is pretty global,
only about 20% of our users
are in the United States.
And one thing that's been
interesting is pretty much
every country, as soon as they apply
their social distancing
measures, we see traffic increase
about one or two days after that.
And it depends on the country.
In some countries it
has more than doubled,
in some countries it has gone
up by 50%, it kinda depends
on the country, but we've seen that.
The first country obviously
where we saw that was China.
About three months ago,
basically the traffic
in China doubled and
it's remained like that.
So you know, I don't know what that means.
A lot of China's back to
normal or mostly normal
yet our traffic remains essentially twice
what it was before.
- And what do you think
is underlying that?
Let's say China for example,
I am curious what language
are folks learning?
Is it all languages, is it English?
And then what do you
think is the motivation?
People are like, "I'm
home, I might as well
do something productive."
Or is there other motivations?
- I think there's both.
I think there's a lot of
kids who had to be in school
and now are home and they're
trying to figure out how to
you know, how to learn whatever
they used to be learning
and a lot of teachers are
telling them to use Duolingo.
But there's also people
who are just bored at home
and you know, it used to be
the case that they used to go
to a restaurant, now that
time is being occupied
for something else.
And they think that you
know, improving their lives
is an important thing.
So I think a lot of people are doing that.
In terms of what languages
people are learning,
it really depends on the country.
In most non-English speaking countries,
people are learning English.
That's the main language that
most everybody is learning.
In the United States, the
biggest language is Spanish,
second is French, then
German, then Japanese.
And then it tapers off quite a bit.
From English, you can learn
about 35 languages on Duolingo.
But some of the smaller ones,
you can learn High Valyrian
from Game of Thrones, you can
learn you know, Esperanto.
You can learn a lot of kind of
some of the smaller languages
but not too many people are learning those
compared to Spanish for example.
- Is High Valyrian a
fully, fleshed out language
that like we could have
a rich conversation in?
- I think so.
I think there's a lot of
strange things, I think it has
a lot of different words
for things like "sword"
or stuff like that.
- Yes, as we know Eskimos have
six words for ice so I guess.
- Let me tell you something
else which I don't know
what this says about the world.
When the seasons were
on for Game of Thrones,
there were more people learning
High Valyrian on Duolingo
than there were people
learning Irish for example
or Scottish which, yeah, I
don't know what this says
about the world but that was the case.
- Fascinating, fascinating.
And what's your sense?
So now there's a lot of parents
and adults who you know,
I have always had
aspirations to get better
at certain languages or
learn certain languages.
What's your general advice there?
I guess this advice would
carry over even if we weren't
in this crisis situation.
Where do you think
Duolingo's really strong
and then what would you
supplement that with
if you really were trying to
you know, get conversational
in Spanish or English
or some other language?
- Yeah, I mean I think,
well the first thing to know
about learning a language is
it takes a while you know?
There's a lot of you know,
kind of fake news marketing
out there that says you can
get fluent in a language
in nine days or whatever,
this is just not true.
It'll take years to get
really fluent in a language.
You can get a lot of
progress in a few months
but if you really, really
wanna get very advanced
in a language, it takes years.
So the first thing I think
you gotta do is build a habit
as with most everything else.
So if you build a habit you
know, spend 15, 20 minutes a day
using Duolingo and you do it
over a long period of time,
you get quite good at it.
You know, things I would
recommend, once you get to a point
where you've done about
half the Duolingo course
or maybe a little more than
that, I would recommend watching
you know, you can watch
Netflix in you know, Spanish
or shows in other languages,
I would recommend watching those.
A lot of times you can watch
them with the subtitles.
Now try watching them with the subtitles
in the language you're
learning, not in English
because then you just won't pay attention.
But if you watch with the
subtitles in Spanish too,
I think that's a pretty good
way to get much better at
you know, after you do Duolingo.
But you can't quite start by doing that
because it's pretty hard
to understand the things.
- Yeah, and I remember
that I used to watch
these Spanish dramas when I
was trying to learn Spanish.
It is effective.
And you've touched on some questions
you know, from Instagram.
Sanoff_7 asks, "How do
you establish a habit
"of learning everyday?"
You just mentioned the
importance of habit.
What do you recommend for
people who are trying that?
- Yeah, well one of the
important things, I think,
is to do it everyday at
the same time, that helps.
If you just for example,
personally the way I do it
is basically as soon as I wake up.
Kinda the first thing
I do is do my Duolingo.
If you pair it with something
else, it's like, "Well,
"I'll do it right after I
brush my teeth," or "I'll do it
"right after lunch," and do
it at the same time everyday,
that seems to really help.
Another thing is that it's
the first maybe 20 ish days
that really matter.
I mean, we see it in our data.
If we can get you to
come back consistently
for about 20 days, then
you'll come back to Duolingo
for very long periods of time.
So you just gotta try to
stick to it for about 20 days.
- I see, and we have some
questions for you in particular
you know, from YouTube.
Reverend Hogwash is
asking, "How many languages
"does Luis speak?"
And you just mentioned that you
are still learning languages,
so I'll extend that.
Not only how many do you
speak but what are you trying
to learn right now?
- Okay, I will say I am
relatively good at English,
I am relatively good at
Spanish, about the same,
English and Spanish.
I'm pretty good at Portuguese,
not quite as good as English but almost,
and then I am intermediate
beginner in French.
The pronunciation is
my nemesis for French.
- And what are you trying
to learn right now?
You mentioned you still have a habit of--
- French, I'm doing
French, that's the one.
I started about a few months
ago, I started with French
after I learned Portuguese,
I started with French
a few months ago.
- Fascinating, and people
are asking, several folks,
this one's from Instagram.
BakerGirl325 asked, "Why
did you create Duolingo?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
You know, I started
Duolingo, it wasn't just me
I mean, there's a whole team
of people that works on it
but at the beginning there were two of us,
me and my cofounder.
His name is Severin and his
last name is Hacker by the way
which is crazy.
But we started it and the
idea was that we wanted
to do something that
would give equal access
to education to everybody.
I mean, that's something
you know about Sal.
In particular for us, neither
of us is from the U.S.
We both had to learn English
when we were growing up.
And English has opened
so many doors for us.
I mean, we were able to
come to the United States,
come to college, etc.
And we knew that in most
countries in the world,
non-English speaking
countries of the world,
knowledge of English can
increase your income potential
by sometimes as much as 100%.
So you can basically double
your income if you know English.
So we knew that but at the
same time also, the ways
to learn languages were
pretty expensive at the time.
So what we wanted to do was
make a way to learn languages
that was going to be free.
And in particular we wanted
to concentrate on English.
It turns out that you know,
English is a big language
for us but now we've basically decided
to teach pretty much every language.
We're not there yet,
there are 6,000 languages
and we only teach 35
but we're working on it.
- And you mentioned
you're free and you know,
this is something we have in common.
We have slightly different models,
we're philanthropically funded,
but it is an interesting question.
I think a couple people
are referring to it.
So how do y'all exist?
How do you make money if
you're giving it away for free?
- Yeah, our mission was
always for anybody to be able
to learn a language
entirely free on Duolingo.
And you know, the question is,
"How are we gonna make money?"
What we decided to do is
kinda this double thing
that is similar to example
of how Spotify makes money.
You can fully learn a language in Duolingo
but after every lesson, you
have to watch a very short ad.
And that's you know,
usually just a static image,
sometimes about you
know, a couple of seconds
where you have to watch an ad.
So basically watch ads,
that's one way we make money
but if you don't wanna watch
the ads, you can also pay
to subscribe to Duolingo
and that turns off the ads.
So it's one of those two ways.
Only 3% of our users pay
us to turn off the ads.
The other 97% are using
it entirely for free.
- Yeah and you know, this is
an important thing to bring up
'cause whether you run as a
not-for-profit or a for profit
there's some way.
A lot of folks I think
imagine Khan Academy still Sal
in a closet someplace or they imagine Luis
and your cofounder Severin Hacker
which is an incredible name
to start a company with
but you know, it costs a lot of resources.
And so you have to figure
out some way to make it work
while still being true to your mission
which I think y'all are doing a great job.
So here's a question, I
don't know if this would fall
under your domain Luis, but
maybe you have a point of view.
I could try to attempt as well.
From YouTube, Ashutosh Tiwari,
who's actually a regular
question asker here,
says, "Hello Luis and Sal,
how do I overcome stuttering
"if you stutter more in English?"
I don't know if this is
something that y'all even address
or do you have a point
of view on this Luis?
- It's not something
that we do with the app.
I actually would not know
how to overcome stuttering.
I myself stutter a little bit.
So if you have good
ideas Sal, let me know.
- Yeah, I'm not an expert in it either.
I have been known to
stutter every now and then.
One thing that was
interesting and I don't know
if this is related to
stuttering but I remember
in my first job, this was at Oracle,
I was a product manager, and
I had to go to this training
on public speaking.
And what they did is they video tapped you
while you gave a speech.
And then when you watched
it, every time you said "um"
in your speech, you also had to say "um"
and everyone in the room said "um."
And that made me very
conscientious of "um."
I still say it but you
don't realize how much
you say words like "um."
And I know every language
has it's own version of "um."
- Not only that, so before
this I was a professor
in computer science and on my
first year, somebody told me
that I should video tape
myself in every lecture
and then watch myself.
First of all, it was
extremely painful and secondly
you know, you start annotating
things like you know,
how many times you say "um."
For me, one of the bad things,
I used the word "like" a lot.
And that was pretty bad.
And I think that actually helped.
- For sure, for sure and
it is a painful experience.
I try not to even watch
these live streams afterwards
as you can imagine.
So from YouTube, the Disney
and Travel Guy asks, "Any tips
"to learn Spanish?
"I'm trying to learn Spanish
on Duolingo and I really want
"to be fluent."
So what should the Disney
and Travel Guy do here Luis?
- Well, keep at it.
Like I said, it takes a
while to become fluent
in a language.
And I would say, once you've
gotten some of the basics
which you know, if you're
maybe down to the middle
of the Duolingo course,
or three quarters down
the Duolingo course you
know, I will say something
that I said before in this.
I would try starting watching
some Netflix shows in Spanish.
There's some really good ones.
I particularly like The Money
Heist but there are others.
And watch it and if it's too hard for you,
try maybe children's shows in Spanish,
they're a little easier.
And also try turning on
the subtitling in Spanish.
That should help.
- Yep, and what is your
view, for someone who wants
to become fluent, what's
your sense of immersion
or some you know, if you
can't travel to the country,
some version of immersion
like getting on video chats
with folks or something like that?
What role does that play?
- All of that helps.
There's a problem with it, it
is most people have too much
social anxiety to get on video
chats with random strangers
in a language that
they're not very good at.
So you know, if you're
able to overcome that,
that's a pretty good solution.
But I think a lot of
people, it's just too much
social pressure for them.
So in that case you know, I don't think
that's absolutely necessary.
I think you can get pretty
far by just using tools
like Duolingo and you
know, watching TV shows
and stuff like that.
- Cool, so if you can obviously Duolingo,
the Netflix in Spanish or
whatever, those are great things
that anyone can do like starting now.
And then if you can overcome
the social pressure,
maybe get on some of--
I don't know their names but
there's ways that you can
get connected with folks and
you know, talk to live people
in the other languages.
So it's interesting.
So this is a question
I guess for both of us
from Instagram, Manfree.ganmore
asks, "Does the speed
"at which you learn affect
the retention of knowledge
"for language or math?"
So you can take the language
side, or if you have
a point of view on the math side.
Do you think that
certain people are better
at languages than others
or do you think it's just
in our minds?
- You know, I do think
there are certain people
who are a little better than others.
There's been research about that.
You know, some of it has to
do with general intelligence
but actually, one of the biggest
things is just being okay
sounding not so smart.
If you're okay with that,
I think you're better
at learning languages.
Because one of the biggest
things that helps you
learn languages faster
is if you start speaking,
the sooner you start
basically able to vocalize
and say stuff, the better.
This is why with Duolingo we recommend
that whenever you're doing
the Duolingo exercises
you just try to mouth them,
just like kinda vocalize
everything that you're seeing.
The sooner you start being
able to talk to others,
the better you get.
And so one of the ways in
which some people are better
at learning languages is they
just basically don't care
as much about sounding you know, broken.
- What you're really saying
is you know, we talk a lot
about things like mindset
and growth mindset
here at Khan academy
and you're really making
the same point.
That people who are more
comfortable putting themselves
out there, they're not
afraid to fail, those folks
in general are gonna grow
more versus the people
who are like, "Oh, I
don't sound intelligent
"in this language yet, let me
just kind of keep preparing."
- Yes.
- And I think the exact
same thing is in math.
You know, I think people are
quick to label themselves
or others are slow
learners or fast learners.
You might see the kid in your
class and she's always getting
the As and you're always
getting a few points less.
"Oh, maybe she's a fast learner."
But the reality is, she
was probably the person
who's always pushing, stepping
out of her comfort zone
willing to get questions wrong.
If she gets the question
wrong, she'll reflect on it.
And she's always trying to draw
connections between things.
I think probably the same
thing is true in languages
as in math, is the more
associations you can make
with something, the more
it'll be fluent to you,
the more it'll come to your--
You know, I'm not a expert
at this but at least
I'm experienced in observing others.
And we've interfaced
with a lot of the experts
on things like grit and growth mindset.
That really seems to
be the best correlate.
- Totally agree.
- So let's see, from Instagram,
SamI804 asks, "How can I
"make the process of
learning a language fun?"
And I'm assuming above and
beyond using the fun Duolingo.
Or how can I make using
Duolingo even more fun?
- The main way is by using Duolingo.
I mean, we spend a lot
of effort making Duolingo
as fun as possible.
There's a lot of features in
Duolingo that make it more fun.
For example, we have these
leader boards with leagues
where the idea is that
whenever you join Duolingo,
you get grouped with about
50 other people who started
around the same time as you.
And for the next week,
you get to see who gets
more experience points.
And the top 10 people in
that group of 50 move on
to the next league.
So everybody starts in the bronze league,
then the top 10 move on
to the silver league,
then next week the top 10
move on to the gold league.
And we have a bunch of leagues like that.
So that competition actually makes the app
significantly more fun.
So I think that's one thing.
Another thing that we
really believe in is that
with Duolingo you can learn you know,
in two to three minute segments.
So anytime you basically,
you are waiting for something
for two minutes or something
you can just get in
a little bit of Duolingo.
And I think that's another
way if you just parse it out
into smaller chunks, that helps.
- That's great.
And on Facebook, a question
from Margo McGinness.
Oh hi Margo, I know Margo.
"My kids need to catch up
with sixth grade Spanish
"for a new school over the summer starting
"from scratch, any tips?"
- Well, download Duolingo.
For sure download Duolingo.
You know, other tips
of things that we hear
other than Duolingo and
maybe watching some Netflix
in Spanish is try reading
the news in Spanish.
There's also some podcasts.
By the way, we have a podcast,
there's the Duolingo Spanish
podcast but there's others
and you can try to
listen to some podcasts.
Some of them are pretty fun.
The Duolingo in particular
one, the Duolingo podcast
is basically real stories
of people from Latin America
about stuff you know, like soccer players
and stuff like that, that
are in very slow Spanish.
And that helps you.
- Yeah, well one of my ideas
just speaking generally
about learning languages, I
have memories of you know,
my family's original tongue is
Bangali but my mom also spoke
you know, Hindi/Urdu
to some of her friends.
And you know, growing up in New Orleans,
there's no immersion for that.
But I would hear her
conversations with her friends
and especially when she was
saying something really juicy
that wasn't meant for my
ears, it would be either
in Bengali, Hindi/Urdu and
that's how I got my functional--
In your brain, it definitely picks up.
- A high reward to understanding.
You got to understand the juicy stuff.
- Right, right, you're
brain wants to understand
what it's not allowed to understand.
But yeah, so yeah, I can imagine
actually Margo's situation.
A lot of parents are trying
to figure out you know,
it might be a situation like
that that you're transitioning
a school or obviously school's
out, can you leverage?
You know, we've been
advocating how you can use
the remainder of the school
year and even the summer
to keep learning in math
but obviously the same thing
can happen in Spanish or
languages or other subjects.
So other questions here.
A few people are asking Luis,
"What was your original tongue?"
Spanish I'm assuming.
- I am a native Spanish speaker, yes.
- Where did you grow up?
- I grew up in Guatemala,
yes right underneath Mexico,
that's where it is.
- And so these other
languages that you've learned,
are learning, like Portuguese
and French, this is just out
of interest or do you have a
lot of friends who travel a lot
to those regions?
- It's out of interest.
I mean you know, I figured I
should learn some languages
given that I am the CEO of Duolingo.
So yes, but it is out of
interest in those languages.
- Right, well great.
Well, let's see, you've
covered a lot of this.
Scott asks, "How many languages
do you offer to learn?"
And I think you said, what was it 35?
- 35, from English, you
can learn 35 languages.
- Yep, and here's a question from YouTube.
Nikhil Govender asks, "If someone has
"a learning disability,"
they're asking both Khan Academy
and Duolingo how it's suited to help.
Any thoughts there Luis?
- Well, depends on what
learning disability.
But I think we know of a lot
of people who have all kinds
of different learning disabilities
who very successfully use Duolingo.
You know, we try to make the
app as accessible as possible.
And yeah, for example we know
a lot of people with dyslexia
that successfully use Duolingo.
You can turn off certain exercise types
and that seems to help.
So depending on the learning disability
I think it can work pretty well.
- Yeah, we see a similar
situation on the Khan Academy side
that we haven't done any focused studies
for many learning disabilities
but to your point,
we're trying to make it
as accessible as possible.
And then we've anecdotally heard
from certain students maybe
with ADHD or dyslexia or some place
on the Asperger's spectrum,
in certain cases you know,
being able to work at your own pace,
slow down things, speed things up,
get immediate feedback on
exercises, things like that
which you know, is true
of both of our platforms
and other online platforms,
that that sometimes
can be helpful.
But I think there's probably
a lot more research to be had.
Well Luis, thanks for joining us
and answering these
questions about language.
I think this is an area
where you know, Khan Academy,
I get a lot of questions,
"When is Khan Academy going
"to teach language?"
And you know, we have Khan
Academy in other languages
but I always say, there's
no need for us to do it
because there's Duolingo.
- Well thank you.
- So go to Duolingo and figure out--
So you know, keep doing
the amazing work y'all do.
- No, and thank you.
And thank you for doing this
and for all the amazing work.
We're huge fans of Khan Academy here.
- Likewise.
- Thank you.
- So everyone, there's a
couple of other questions
that y'all are asking
generally but I will just say
you know, we're doing this everyday
and I think we're coming
up to the half hour.
But you know, keep your questions going.
If I can't get them in over
today or over the next few days,
then I will try to answer
them in future days.
But as I mentioned, this is
just a forum for all of us
to stay in touch, stay connected
during the school closures,
talk about things that might
be relevant for getting you
through the school closures
or things that might just be interesting
since we're all socially distanced now.
Expect over the next few
weeks, we will have many other
interesting guests like
Luis to talk about anything
from how you might try to
tackle a certain subject,
how you might try to stay
just happy and content
in this otherwise stressful period
or things about how you
can be creative at home
or what's the state of the economy?
I'll also put my plug in
again, reminder that we are
a not-for-profit.
If you are in a position
to do so, please think
about donating to Khan Academy.
We are running at a deficit,
especially given all of
the traffic and the use of the resources
because of this crisis.
So I'll let y'all go.
Thank you for coming to the
Homeroom live stream today.
I actually have my daughter
with me, can I show you Diya?
She's right here, let me
see if I can, there she is.
There she is, she's ignoring me.
- What?
- No, she's got headphones on but yeah,
she was my special guest.
I wanted her to be in
the live stream with me
but she didn't want to.
But I'll let y'all go and
I'll see you tomorrow.
Stay safe, stay healthy.